ahí está mi followers
gracias
cuántos de vosotros compráis por
internet por favor levanta la mano
y ahora mantenerla levantada si sois de
amazon prime
qué barbaridad yo también y es
fantástico verdad por qué
en un momento y estés donde estés en el
sofá en la playa
puedes encontrar lo que necesitas
comprarlo y magia al día siguiente lo
tienes en tu casa pues bien eso no es
magia
es
logística
pero como si esto fuera a hogwarts se
puede estudiar aquí mismo en el campus
de alcoy de la upv
los magos no desvelan sus secretos pero
en los próximos minutos voy a mostraros
cómo enseño los mejores trucos de la
logística a los alumnos los que serán
los futuros directivos de las empresas a
las que compráis con vuestros
dispositivos móviles
la logística es la gestión coordinada
del flujo de los productos el transporte
el almacenaje y de toda la información
necesaria y sin duda es uno de los
problemas más difíciles a los que las
empresas se tienen que enfrentar
sí sí sí ya sé ya sé seguro que estáis
pensando venga al es ya será menos todos
los profesores siempre decís que esta
asignatura es la más difícil la más
importante
bueno si estáis pensando en un cliente
al que al día siguiente hay que
entregarle su paquete pues parece
sencillo el problema es que no es ni uno
ni dos son cientos de miles millones los
paquetes que ahora mismo están viajando
por todo el planeta y se están
gestionando para que mañana lleguen a su
destino
mirad cada vez que hacéis esto
esto me gusta
y lo quiero lo quiero azul
y esto otro también
los quiero plus lo quiero para mañana a
clic clic lo quiero ya haga clic clic
clic clic
o peor aún al día siguiente pues ya no
me gusta lo quiero devolver
con este simple gesto estáis creando
nuevos problemas a las empresas
en realidad es como un reto que va
pasando de unos a otros los clientes
exigen soluciones a las empresas las
empresas tienen que buscar profesionales
que les resuelvan sus problemas y los
alumnos los futuros profesionales tienen
que aprender cómo resolverlos
así que con este simple gesto y sin
saberlo también nos estáis poniendo en
apuros a los profesores
hasta hace más bien poco yo daba clases
con esto
sabéis qué es
y algún veterano hay por ahí
es un acetato el soporte sobre el que se
imprimían las diapositivas que con un
retroproyector se mostraban en el aula
los alumnos además de tener varios
libros y tomar apuntes tenían que
estudiar cientos de fotocopias de estos
acetatos
cuando por fin el proyecto digital llegó
al aula pues la cosa no fue mejor porque
como yo ya no tenía que imprimirlas
ahora podía proyectar más diapositivas
diapositivas y más diapositivas
completamente llenas de texto
entre nosotros
unas chuletas fantásticas para el
profesor
pero para el alumno
os puedo asegurar que tan solo hacen
falta dos o tres de estas diapositivas
mal diseñadas y mal utilizadas para
tener
un somnífero de primera
pero vamos a ver
verdad que os gusta vivir experiencias
emocionantes como el té tx y aprender
cosas nuevas sí o no no soy yo sí o no
entonces porque en el aula donde todos
los días aprenden cosas nuevas no se
tienen también experiencias emocionantes
mi problema no era que mis alumnos no
quisieran estudiar el verdadero problema
era que yo había liquidado su pasión por
aprender
y lo que de verdad me quitaba el sueño
es que sabía que era mi responsabilidad
durante mucho tiempo pensé
cómo puedo enseñar el reto de la
logística
tan sólo tenía claro una cosa los
alumnos no deben de ser meros
espectadores de un discurso aburrido
sino que tienen que ser los
protagonistas de un reto emocionante
tal vez lo ideal hubiera sido a
los alumnos y llevarlos a una empresa
real a vivir una experiencia emocionante
y real verdad pero claro eso no era
posible así que esta pregunta se
convirtió se convirtió en una obsesión
hasta que un día
tuve un momento eureka
no llevaría a los alumnos a la empresa
traería la empresa al aula pero cómo
magia haciendo la pequeña
esto es una empresa que si cabe en el
aula y dónde aprender los mejores trucos
de la logística lo que está construido a
partir de dos ideas muy sencillas los
alumnos son los protagonistas en esta
simulación logística cada alumno debe de
adoptar el rol de uno de los integrantes
de la empresa la directora de
operaciones el jefe de almacén él piquer
el reponedor son estas personas las que
toman todas las decisiones y realizan
todas las acciones así que el alumno
aprende haciendo cosas y en segundo
lugar es un reto emocionante porque al
asumir en primera persona el reto de la
logística servir a los clientes de la
mejor forma posible no solamente se está
recreando una experiencia empresarial
real sino que también nos emocionamos se
aprende con emoción así que yo es como
como una pócima mágica que combina el
aprendizaje basado en proyectos el
aprendizaje basado en el juego la
simulación y los juegos de rol con esta
pócima parece que los alumnos aprenden
casi sin darse cuenta
desde que empecé a usar yo hace 5 años
las clases ya no son lo mismo por aquí
por aquí han pasado cientos de alumnos
de grado de máster pero también de
muchas empresas valencianas y es que si
de pequeños aprendemos muchas cosas
jugando porque nos seguirá haciendo la
de mayores mira cuando jugamos
experimentamos
aprendemos lo que funciona
y lo que no
y también nos emocionamos en nuestro
cerebro se libera una sustancia llamada
dopamina que ayudará a recordar lo que
estamos aprendiendo
una de las cosas que más me emociona a
mí es ver como mis alumnos piensan
discuten y trabajan en equipo
este es un truco fundamental porque por
muy inteligentes que vosotros seáis
vosotros solos no podréis resolver un
problema de este orden de magnitud
recordad millones de paquetes así que
vais a tener que trabajar con otras
personas diferentes a vosotros de otra
nacionalidad otra cultura que tengan
habilidades complementarias a la vuestra
pero tal vez algún interés contrario al
tuyo
en logística no solo es importante una
buena comunicación sino que es
fundamental una buena coordinación ya
que son muchas las empresas y las
personas las que se coordinan para que
mañana nuestro pedido llegue a tiempo en
perfectas condiciones en estos sistemas
tan complejos es imprescindible tener lo
que se denomina visión del proceso y
mirad al hacer la empresa pequeña
es como si vosotros crecieran y os
convirtieran en gigantes en liliput y
desde aquí tenéis la perspectiva
perfecta para comprender el sistema y
sus elementos y cuando uno comprende
cómo funcionan las cosas y sus
conexiones sin duda es mucho más fácil
tomar decisiones
otro de los trucos fundamentales de la
logística es la planificación sabíais
qué logística todo se planifica hacia
atrás mirar es como imaginar el instante
futuro en el que entregas el periodo a
tu cliente y fueras retrocediendo en el
tiempo hasta llegar al momento actual a
cada fotograma tendréis que decidir qué
recursos utilizar y cómo hacerlo para
que por ejemplo el tiempo total del
proceso sea mínimo y el coste también
curioso verdad si solo también los
juegos de estrategia en el ordenador o
en la videoconsola seréis muy buenos en
el juego de la logística
la verdad que me siento muy afortunado
de trabajar en la universidad en estos
años he vivido momentos muy divertidos y
emocionantes con mis alumnos a veces
cuando el alumno llega a clase y se ve
todo esto se queda como como paralizado
y emocionado a la vez sabe que tiene que
jugar pero es como si hubiera olvidado
cómo hacerlo
otras veces en cambio
profesionales con traje corbata y su
super teléfono móvil completamente
enganchados al juego no querían volver a
trabajar
álex dejan los 5 minutos más
pero también como las empresas se suelen
reproducir momentos difíciles de tensión
por falta de planificación va la
comunicación no discusión es que hay que
saber gestionar y hay que saber
solucionar
gracias a los alumnos en estos años se
ha aprendido lo que no está escrito
las personas son lo más importante
pienso además que es el profesor no es
un trabajo
sino que es un compromiso con la
sociedad la sociedad del futuro
el alumno no tiene que aprender más sino
que tiene que aprender mejor
porque de nada sirve si no lo comprende
o mañana no lo recuerda
así que los profesores tenemos que hacer
lo imposible para que eso no suceda y si
eso implica ser atrevido original y
salirnos o ampliar nuestra zona de
confort pues tenemos que hacer lo que
puede pasar que nos equivoquemos
bueno equivocarse es otra forma de decir
aprender
aprender también es experimentar jugar
tocar hacer y por supuesto emocionarse
bueno como veis ya estoy con las
conclusiones si parece que voy a
terminar de un momento a otro
pero todavía queda un truco más
las empresas más inteligentes son las
que escuchan a los clientes
y yo en estos años ha aprendido a
escuchar a los míos los alumnos
son ellos los que me dicen lo que
funciona y lo que no
y también me piden que la experiencia
sea más divertida más emocionante pero
me exigen que sea lo más compleja y real
posible lo más parecida a una empresa de
verdad
por eso en estos dos últimos años he
estado trabajando en una nueva versión
del juego que utiliza la realidad
virtual
alcoy
cuando me pongo las gafas me tele
transportó a una empresa de verdad
lo veo todo en tres dimensiones la
escala real
y con estos mandos puedo desplazarme e
interactuar con el mundo que me rodea
lo primero que tengo que hacer los lunes
por la mañana es entrar en la oficina
e imprimir los pedidos de los clientes
[Música]
pero mientras tanto
os apetece un café
bueno ya es hora de ponernos a trabajar
así que voy a entrar en el almacén
y voy a buscar los productos que me han
pedido
tendré que cada una de estas cajas
y dejarlas sobre el palé
pero cuidado que aquí también hay
gravedad así que podría provocar algún
accidente
veamos que hay por aquí
alguien ha olvidado borrar la pizarra
desde aquí tengo buenas vistas
y se activó el modo de realidad
aumentada realidad aumentada activada de
pronto tengo acceso instantáneo
referencias a algunos indicadores
rotación como la rotación que me ayudan
a tomar decisiones y también puedo
buscar fácilmente
los productos que necesito
en realidad virtual además puedo tener
superpoderes vista interior activada por
ejemplo puedo ver el interior de los
camiones
fantástico verdad
pero sin duda vista interior desde ante
nada activada es sin duda una de las
cosas
que más gusta
vista interior desactivada que más gusta
y emoción a mis alumnos es poder manejar
la transporta o una carretilla elevadora
la mejilla contra pesada lista
bueno cuidado que esto no es tan fácil
como parece
no tengo el carnet vehículo aparcado
para seguir por aquí
mi objetivo es que dentro de muy poco le
pueda decir a los alumnos no abráis los
libros vamos a separar las mesas
ponernos las gafas que empieza la clase
será será como si las paredes del aula
desaparecieran y todos aprendiéramos
jugando en una empresa de verdad será
una experiencia prime como vosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]